welcome witches I'm your hi hostess
Liana Galera and by now you all should
have benched part two of chilling
Adventures of Sabrina and if you haven't
spoiler alert
get out of here hop on your broomstick
get out of here let's fly back once
you're done because we are about to
discuss all of these spellbinding twists
and bewitching turns with Satan himself
that's right after Luke Cook is here and
I'm so thrilled about this right now
hello welcome to the witches Council
thank you for having me it's so nice
meeting you and for all the fans out
there they're seeing you for the very
first time yes as Satan as Satan yes as
well not as Satan as Luke yes we're all
your fans are tuning in right now I will
be taking your comments so send them in
to us right now I'll pass them along to
Luke but I've got to say congratulations
thank you what a wicked debut you've had
I know what a moment like what an
introduction to me in a loincloth and
yeah yeah talk to me about when you were
auditioning for this did you know the
part you're going in for I knew that it
was for Lucifer I I thought it was one
of the worst auditions I've ever done to
be honest I've never walked out of an
audition wanted to punch something so
badly I just thought it was an absolute
failure and then I got the call the next
day and it turns out it was I was maybe
good it was a big success
yeah well yeah I loved the episode I
think it turned out great yeah I think
you need to share with the fans what
made this episode so particularly
wonderful what do your parents do oh my
gosh well my father is a minister
Presbyterian minister and god bless them
they they they heard that I was playing
Satan and every song and I'd send them a
video just saying you following your
false gods and like get sending them a
message from Satan but they watched it
and they really liked it and they were
very proud of me but I love that they
watched it in the first introduction of
you isn't a loincloth loincloth coming
out of a cave like a satanic cave but
your chemistry with Michele was
absolutely amazing how did you guys find
that on screen
mystery together I mean I think that
where I think I would say that we're
similar people yes we're both bold was a
great hair true in fact we felt we found
a lot and I was like great hair she's
had YouTube that was our first line to
each other for even introduced no she's
she's just a sassy wonderful person
we've got along great uh and what was it
like for you finding that on-screen bond
with Kiernan who now know is Lucifer's
daughter I know well I mean she makes it
so easy because well because she makes
such great conversation with you off off
camera that I like completely at ease
when she comes on and it was such a
dream working with her she's a great
actress when you when did you find out
the twist that Sabrina Spellman was
actually Lucifer Morningstar daughter
when I first well we did the table read
with the whole cast and I was like okay
this is a fairly important thing like I
mean we've been talking about the Dark
Lord for two seasons and then I come in
and I'm like okay well that's a big
twist
I am her daddy I called it my I called I
said I'm your daddy
I know I don't know what it means what I
love so sure either well speaking of
internet memes my favorite mean that's
out there right now for which for
chilling Adventures of Sabrina is it
goes no one and then it goes I am
Sabrina but now I think she has to start
saying I am Sabrina Morningstar yes
could she I mean I'm
it's one of my fatherly and things that
I must say she has to do but I loved
that we got to see her serve as your
queen for a hot second just a hot second
then just a hot second threw me into her
boyfriend
we're coming back to that but first
let's talk about the musical moment oh
yeah that was such a fun twist to see on
the show what was it like being on set
for that much oh it's like amazing cuz
all these people were singing it it was
loud and Keenan's an amazing singer and
dancer the only thing I didn't like
about it was I didn't get to sing it
because I loved Phantom of the Opera I
was like I know these words I'm not
saying this but no they didn't give me
the opportunity it's fine the costumes
looked amazing
yes your costumes were great what was
your favorite thing to put on all that
big gold one for sure but the deepest
fees like this there's no deeper V than
that like any deeper and it's just not a
show it's just not a shirt yeah it's a
hoodie with just a little bit at the
bottom did you meet the actor who plays
the other Dark Lord yes the Beast
version yes he's amazing and like much
taller than I am and I'm six foot four
and he's even taller than me it's very
weird we need six foot four and you meet
someone told on you because like you
never look up here anyway he's a lovely
guy we've got our first fan comment
right now from the lovely Tabitha and
she wants to know what was it like
getting into this character hi Tabitha
getting into this character is a lot of
a lot of fun I think the devil has his
charms that's what I was always thinking
I was thinking gosh she's got to be
charming and he's evil and I think we're
all capable of great evil it's a very
heavy thing to say but that's how you
get into it I feel like you're gonna be
walking along the street now people are
just gonna be like praise Satan yeah
nice and I'll give them a little wave
yes thank you
but did you tell me there's a priest
Satan at certain moments on set yes the
way that it's the best it's the best
crew you could ever be a part of if you
sneeze on the set I'm Sabrina
everybody goes hey so Jung and it's
actually a competition for who can say
the loudest so it's absolutely crazy you
just gonna be careful when you're
rolling then yes you know do you not see
yes Sasha Shelton says I just finished
part 2 oh my gosh look at the ending
let's talk about this ending yeah it's
heavy isn't it Yasha
okay so NIC essentially sacrificed
himself to be the human vessel to hold
Lucifer within himself am I getting this
right that's correct
okay that's correct what was your
reaction when you read that twist at the
table read that I'm going into Nick I
mean it's like a kind of Lucifer
intercourse it was hilarious I mean I
was like great anyway I think it's great
because at one point you like oh no now
now Nick is no longer the heartthrob but
he's like he's more of a heartthrob now
he's like double for one movie like
ethnic we hate him and
he's like I'll do it I can hold him and
you're like I love him again but I also
I love the fact that like the Dark Lord
told Nick like get close to this girl
and then Sabrina was like so taken aback
by that but it's like you have to do it
the Dark Lord says and it's not like he
did anything bad he just want to get
close to you he actually fell for you so
yeah I think you really are trying to
forgive yeah I mean in the grand scheme
of betrayals in this show to me that was
the biggest one and as well as he really
does love her yeah so it's like yeah he
was manipulating it but then he's like
as he's manipulate he's like wait I
actually really do like her I think it's
hot so you are now trapped in Nick's
scratches body in hell and it is being
ruled over by Lilith and the Queen of
Hell let me just say there are worse
bodies did he tracked it how about his
rippling abs oh my gosh that scene with
him and Kenan I mean there were quite a
few scenes yes I'm glad your parents
didn't watch all of part two because it
got sexy this year guys I said guys just
watch that episode no more animal I'm
sorry if I'm saying this wrong says what
is the future of Lucifer Morningstar now
that he's in the body of a witch yes I I
wish I could answer that for was it a
yeah
a man mall and mall I wish I can answer
that for you but I don't even know
myself it's all a mystery well going off
of that Deepika wants to know will we
see more of you on the show in the
future I hope so I haven't heard
anything but yes fingers crossed
I killed oh yes healthy a kill says are
we gonna see more of the Dark Lord in
part three and so we know that we're not
quite sure yet
yeah Avery wants to know what was your
favorite moment from season two a moment
from season two I mean honestly it was
holding a holding a dagger up to Hildur
and Zelda's neck but yeah how did you
guys do that I know you guys have a lot
of practical effects on this show so was
that something that was actually
happening on set yeah it's the way that
that works is this no one there's not
like a person in a green suit holding it
up they just do that after but yeah but
it was just a fun scene
and just to work of Miranda Otto and
Lucy Roche of whom like Lucy Walsh for
me was I was a little bit starstruck oh
yes I love you of course yeah anyway
she's nicest person and hilarious
endlessly yeah love her yeah I love the
fact that they do have a lot of
practical effects on the shows that when
you are doing these spells it feels like
you actually have the power did you have
any like moments like that on set where
you're like oh well yes because there
were these there were these flashes of
lightning going off as that scene was
happening in these gusts of wind as if I
had done that and so I really did feel
like like we had like a hundred people
in the crew like making wind and I was
like but it was all thank like what the
heaven is going on here yeah and then I
you know and then I go home and I'm just
eating popcorn I'm like yep I'm not in
any way powerful how'd you like
Vancouver oh thank you was fantastic and
cool and rainy and a nice break from Los
Angeles it's the perfect setting for the
show though yes I was up there for the
second-to-last episode the mantric
episode yeah and we were in the middle
of the Vancouver wilderness it was
freezing but so was it absolutely
chilling when you were on set as well
absolutely chilling but they take such
great care of you they're always like
you okay and I had to be naked in that
way though like as an FYI that's where I
was going
yes like there was a six think there was
a 5 a.m. call one morning and I had to
get out and it's a well the way that
they do the nudity stuff is it actually
that loincloth is put in their idea was
antara long loincloth so I was in a
thong and magic yes Wow the magic of
moviemaking and I was in the sand but it
was - whatever so that was the very
first day I was you know that original
scene with the young list yeah that was
the first day she's great Jen oh yeah
yes and that was an amazing set like out
in the middle of nowhere outside of
Vancouver and but freezing like beyond
freezing
Dina wants to know have you thought of
an hour an alternative ending for this
season or have you imagined the ending
before reading oh yeah how did you when
you found out that you got this part how
did you originally envisioned what was
happen oh gosh I wish I could answer
that I didn't think of anything about
the actual ending I thought me and I
thought I care about this I thought that
me and Sabrina could just have a normal
life of domesticity she'd move in and
we'd make smoothies every day that's
what father's do with a diner and get a
dog dog and just be your own family yeah
your own little wicked little family
maybe at some point I'll find you know a
mrs. Satan and we can all live happily
ever after
it was interesting though that if he's
the Dark Lord that he wanted his
daughter to be Queen I'm not sure
exactly how the royal lineage
you know he's Satan so incest is never
out of the question
okay I'm sorry that's true he's hopeful
okay yeah well what did you Sasha wants
to know what did you think of the Dark
Lord and Lilith's relationship Oh
complicated I know it is complicated
well that's something that I thought of
I was like well Lilith and him were
lovers you know that's how they started
and they obviously fell out because he
wasn't giving her power and he was
obsessed with himself as an artist I've
often think that like there's a way that
that romance can be re-ignited I
actually thought that it might go there
it'll be interesting to see if we still
have the lovely Michelle Gomez in part
three because she kind of went back into
Miss Warhol's body so but I can't
imagine anyone playing madam Satan
except for her I know well I would love
I would just love to watch the acting
challenge to Michelle Gomez of her
playing throughout a season's worth
having to be like madam Satan and
there's an actress oh you can do it I
feel like I think she could I think she
could we're gonna take a couple more fan
questions
Meghan Khan wants to know oh she says
that's the sweetest thing ever
so thank you Meghan we were glad that
you're thinking what he's thinking of
sweet the will of Artie says what's it
like working with the rest of the cast I
just thought that would that they just I
mean if you don't like it's not to be
kind of singing but they're so cute like
I just wanted to hug them all and love
them all that's so fantastic and the
youngins oh well it's kind of a break in
age in between there's like there's
there's this high schoolers and then
there's there aren't ease and things
like that I got along well with so with
all of them just all of them they're
just a treat to work with gqo wants to
know what was
most challenging scene the most
challenging scene was with madam Satan
was with Michelle Gomez because that was
my second day on set I was in skin
colored thong and I had to kind of come
in and control her yeah and she's a very
powerful woman off set and on set and so
that was just challenging to do it in a
skin colored thong it's hard to be
powerful at a skin colored thong it
makes you feel pathetic erin is giving
us a great question right now because I
actually asked the entire chilling
Adventures of Sabrina cast the same
question so thank you Erin Erin wants to
know are you team Harvey or team Nick I
thinks he thought a team javis got his
girl I'm team Nick yeah oh yeah yeah
Nick and Sabrina are hot that's a thing
are you only saying that because you're
technically trapped in Nick's body right
now well I just think javis got his own
thing going on and you know he's got
endless babes he'll be fine
plenty of fish in the sea do you think
there's ever gonna be a time where we
could see the Dark Lord maybe not be so
dark to be nice wouldn't it just at
least I don't
I'll just get along everything is like
the end of the world this show it's like
oh man let's just see them go to like a
dance I know we've got to be a funny
that'd be a funny meeting in the writers
room like how do we make Satan not so
Satan me yeah can he be just like cute
for one yeah I don't think that's Satan
it's quirky yeah I hope so since the
show has premiered fans have been
binging it like crazy and I understand
that you've been getting some
interesting teens Deanna people slidin
up in the DMS and like unbold
too like I've slid up into people's DMS
before but it's always like hey how are
you big fan these ones are just right to
the point of what they want which is
like hey show me a butt or something we
just watched the episode yes exactly it
was all right there for you it's all
Netflix you can watch it whenever you
want you know like you don't have to I
can't send pictures of my bottom what
has been the number one question the
fans have had for you so far because
it's really just been a bit of a
whirlwind weekend for you yeah
I'd say the question most people are
asking is semi pictures of you but just
endlessly that's the biggest question
Noah Harris says when my sister found
out that the Dark Lord was Sabrina's dad
she fell to the floor and did not move
and then Noah says Oh what do you think
oh I love Riverdale but wait has she
moved yet I think she's still in the
ground so she's okay yeah Wow but yeah
what do you think of Riverdale
I do like room ooh dad they're all so
attractive I know all right
yeah it's really unfortunate there's
only so much of that I can take if I got
it it's like reading a fashion magazine
of mine I feel ugly out here
there is no mediocre-looking people in
Riverdale Street chilling adventures
every though this is TV baby every
Riverdale everyone's gorgeous
we need like another spin-off where it's
like the real world is the real world
well I they do do they do reality TV
that you can watch of that if you do
they should do a reality show about
people who think they which is I think
it's called Vanderpump rules
they call themselves which is a wee ho
so my guilty pleasure of mine is love
Island I love love Island sorry we're
getting way off topic we will discuss
this hailey last year way off topic
right now okay lastly see heart says
what's the goat leg like the goat leg is
horrifying like you touch it as a goof
what is this giant weird thing it's
gross good question
did you like was it attached to your
actual leg sometimes they would have
like tie it to my leg and sometimes that
would make me wear a gray sock and they
just put it over the computer whatever
but sometimes I would have to wear it
and it's all like kind of slightly hairy
like not a very hairy very hairy I could
take but only slightly or it's it's like
so did you always have the gold leg like
oh it's just okay I kind of see that as
like evil taking over his body and the
animal taking over his body
yeah like yes it's you because we saw in
the flashbacks like he didn't always
have the goat leg yes and then he yes
I'd say that's that's symbolic of
something
lastly what do you want to say to
the chilling fans out there who have
benched the show they fell in love with
you they're having conflicting thoughts
yes well I would say I'm not mean I'm
not trying to ruin Sabrina's life don't
come after my life because I it's just a
character I'm actually quite a nice
person yes Luke thank you so much for
joining us for this special LIVE episode
of witches Council and for all you fans
right now comment down below with your
favorite moments from chilling
Adventures of Sabrina part 2 and we will
see you next time bye guys see you later
[Music]
you